one of the most uh difficult interviews
i've ever had to conduct in my entire
career
was conducting the interview with sean
payton after he just won the super bowl
live on nfl network where he was so
amped up with that win
he slapped my hand i extended a tissue
shake his hand he came with it he
slapped it so hard i did not have
feeling in the right arm
for the first half of that interview
i mean it just you know how he oh yeah i
think he gave me a stinger
and i thought to myself literally four
or five minutes in i'm like
will i get the feeling back in my arm
before the end of this show
so i'm glad i guess i'm glad this will
be a phone interview and uh socially
distant anyway but uh
844 204 rich is the number to dial here
on the show
uh again justin herbert uh of the los
angeles chargers will be joining us in
our number two so we've got some great
guests the first half of our show
followed up by kyle
brandt and josh dumel great guests in
the second half of our show
back here on the rich eisen show one big
happy simulcast family
and joining me here on the show is the
head coach of the current one seed in
the nfc
entering thanksgiving weekend he is sean
payton how are you sir
rich i'm doing well like i can i can
think of that moment and
my my first thought is if you guys had a
blue tent on set they would have taken
you back in the tent to evaluate
yourself
this did predate the blue tent arrow
when you came on after winning the super
bowl and slapped my hand so hard i did
not have feeling in it for the first
half of that interview
that is true rich is being evaluated
i have to take it one question at a time
you know it's it's question a question i
was literally questioned a question
in that interview i really wasn't but
thankfully marshall was there
yeah absolutely it's good to be on it's
good to have you here uh anything going
on in your world these days huh nothing
going on
these days your neck of the woods well
look thanksgiving week
one of the one of the challenges i think
in our league and it's for every team
is it's it's tough on the holidays uh
particularly either thanksgiving and
christmas
and what i mean by that scheduling wise
is there's a handful of teams that play
tomorrow
uh that's been us really the last few
years um
but when you're not playing you're
wanting to get uh your your players and
staff home after practice tomorrow and
so you
you double up on your preparation nights
so uh instead of each night doing one
segment of your install
as a staff you're you're having to uh
because they're gonna be home on
thursday night you're having to you know
knock out your third down your red zone
your goal line kind of all of it uh
tonight and uh it's just part of the
deal though and we played on
thanksgiving
this year we happen to play on christmas
but
um yeah we're we're looking forward this
next game is in denver
and uh they're coming off a big win and
you know it's the next
it's the next team up it's the next
challenge in front of us yeah and then
obviously you saw what denver was able
to do to
a quarterback in his fourth career start
in tua
and now you've got taysom hill in his
second career start do you view tasem
as a rookie quarterback technically just
because again he had only 19
throws in his career going into
the the win this past weekend how do you
approach taysom
here yeah i think that's fair relative
to his reps
and then the the only other thing that
maybe is a little bit
more calming is that he's played a lot
of football now
it hasn't been at the quarterback
position at times he's been more of a
wildcat quarterback
but um yeah the first the first quarter
of last week's game there's
certainly a lot of pressure on anybody
who's starting their first game and
i thought he handled it well settled in
and and really functioned well as the
game wore on we played
outstanding defense um we have seen you
know the
the denver tape versus miami i i think
vic
fangio's done a fantastic job always
defensively they're starting and playing
a young quarterback not a rookie but
uh they they played very well last
weekend so uh when was the first time
you laid eyes on taysom hill
sean first time it is really how we
ended up finding
finding him um the final cut down every
year comes
right before the the first weekend of
the regular season so the weekend prior
every team cuts down to their
other final 53 at that time and so
there's a lot of tape everyone's
watching for for roster cuts
and they'd ask me to look at a practice
squad
candidate receiver uh and it was
max mccaffrey who who coincidentally we
had
seen a little bit of when he was with us
briefly
and so i was watching green bay film
of the preseason and it was a cut up
made of
max mccaffrey and it just so happened
the plays that he's getting in or the
second half of preseason games and they
all happen to be with
uh this quarterback number seven taysom
hill and and so as i'm watching the cut
up
i couldn't help but notice uh the
quarterback as well he made a few big
plays he scrambled gained eight nine
yards there's a play where he steps up
in the pocket and he ran for 33 yards
and a touchdown
and the other thing that was noticeable
was when he scored on that play
all 10 other players were in the end
zone you know celebrating with them and
so
you could tell on film uh this was a
young player in his rookie year out of
byu that uh
that his teammates certainly were
playing for and
i called ireland in and i said hey i'm i
mean
i'm comfortable we were looking at the
decision if we could get max mccaffrey
on the practice squad here
uh let's go ahead and do that but i want
to look at all of
this this this hill that i'm looking at
and i said this isn't sean hill from
maryland still in the league is it
and then no he said this is taysom hill
and so we put a cut up together we
watched all of his stuff
and when it ended i turned and said to
him what don't we like about this guy
you know in other words
and we decided to put a claim in for him
and so
basically for for the audience um
when the cuts are made at training camp
there's a claiming order and it's the
draft order that year and so
uh the team that picked first in the
draft would have first claim
um and so when all these cuts are made
you'll see claims put in
and if three or four teams claim an
individual player it's awarded to the
the highest seated claim the first the
second all the way back to the super
bowl winner
i think we were claiming 11 that year
and
i was just worried that maybe someone
ahead of us claimed the player but
fortunately with
with that claim we weren't we were
awarded the player so we really got him
uh at the week before the start of the
regular season we were fortunate
and you know i'm sure glad we did so uh
sean payton here on the rich eisen show
so many questions uh about pa uh uh
about
taysom hill now moving forward um and
and why
he's in there at all i just want to go
down what what i've heard and the
narratives that we've been
we've been told and um you know and
let's let's go one by one here that he's
gotten the start here
because this was your plan all along
that if if
if brees was going to be out for any
significant amount of time this was your
plan all along
and you told tasem that this would be
his opportunity if it came about
and you wanted to be a man of your word
are all those factual
right there yeah they are you know in
the off season
we were signing him and you know a
couple questions
came up you know we wanted to back off
the kickoff and kick return phase of
special teams those were
some snaps we felt we could hold on he
was still going to work as our
personal protector on punt he was still
going to be on our
punt rush punt block uh he's he's an
outstanding special teams player
and i think the feeling going in and
jamis drew all these guys knew that if
something happened in game
it would be too difficult to try to um
replace all the reps he's had in in
these other spots also playing a you
know kind of a receiver tight end for us
and so
uh james had an outstanding camp uh and
we we feel great about the progress he's
made in
in really that's been a good addition so
uh it sure enough happened that way
where
drew couldn't finish the second half of
a game here a week ago and
james went in right away and and did a
great job
but i told taysom you know in the event
that there's an injury like last year
where the following week
we started teddy uh that i would give
you that opportunity and
i think the challenge for so many people
to cover us or for anybody that's
watched us
is you you kind of only see him in one
role because that's all
that's all the uh uh the exposure you
have
and and so you see him running the ball
you see him throwing it some you see him
in a lot of different
but we're able to see him as a
quarterback
you know all throughout the offseason
throughout the training camp and
he meets with the quarterbacks so our
exposure
would be a little bit uh more extensive
if you will
to to him playing quarterback then uh
anyone else who was just watching us and
i totally understood last week
that you know there's a lot of pressure
going into a starter and i think there
was
an assumption that hey it was going to
be jameis and
and i think when everyone finds out it's
it's it's not it there's that immediate
well why are they doing this and a lot
of it had to do with just
our exposure to him playing quarterback
uh
that you might not have seen on tv and
then of course you signed him to a
contract that
uh i guess to use the phrase that it's
been associated with taste him so much
it's he's the most expensive swiss army
knife maybe in nfl history
uh but the idea is that maybe he is the
guy
after drew decides to go to nbc which
almost happened this year and we know uh
did not
um is this did you are you using these
games without drew to to kick the tires
on whether
taysom hill is your next quarterback are
you technically as a one seed
using this time as a slightly a little
bit of a laboratory to see if this works
coach yeah i would say this though our
job to this team
right now is to win and uh
in and certainly when any players
playing you're evaluating the player but
um i i think that you know
first and foremost were we're looking at
trying to win each week
and and put ourselves in the best
position at the end of the season so
uh you know drew went to ir hopefully
he's back sooner than later
uh and and healthy in the meantime
uh both taysom and james are getting
snaps
preparing to help us do that to help us
win the next game
and you know there's so many things he
can do
uh that are unique obviously uh
you know it's it's a it's a different
type of player he's
uh he's close to 238 240 pounds he's
strong
he's got a good arm uh i thought he did
a good job last week in in
in his start like i said he made some
that then there's some off schedule
plays that
where he scrambles and scores his first
touchdown and
um so we we've just got to keep looking
at ways to put him in a position to be
successful but by no means
uh do we have that luxury to just get a
free evaluation
uh what's most important is finding a
way to win this game
sean payton here uh on the rich eisen
show and i guess all that said i think i
did see
you say after the game that there was
you know uh some pressure involved with
this decision that you made and
and pressure for hill to uh
make it cash and then that happened and
it seems that the
lid off the the boiling pot uh was
placed
right in the twitter hands of roddy
white coach uh we
we noticed you retweeted uh the famed uh
atlanta falcon we had some fun with this
rivalry we uh
every year i mean it's always it's
always a tough battle last year we split
uh uh they beat us at home and we were
able to get a win on the road and then
this year
you know we play this weekend and we
turn around and go to atlanta so
um i i can remember a lot a lot of games
uh roddy competing on the field he was a
tremendous player
and uh that was just one of those
moments i couldn't help myself
[Laughter]
now was there some because again i know
you're not spending a lot of your time
you know scrolling on twitter looking
for trolls but
did someone on your staff like say hey
roddy did this and you're like
actually i like four or five years ago i
don't know whenever i start whenever i
got twitter i followed him just
just because he was a good player in our
division so i've always followed him
um i don't think i ever got to follow
back but that doesn't matter
not now i had just i had just come
across a couple of the tweets and i
thought man i hadn't heard from him in a
while and it was just
look he's he's fired up i'm sure pulling
for his team and
uh it's all good it is all good sean
payton here uh on the rich eisen show
how
is drew feeling uh we heard uh about the
reports out there the number of ribs
that were broken
made me actually look up how many ribs a
human being has
coach well listen i feel like ed waters
kept us up to date with weekly
rib fractures and it's just continued to
climb so
uh but he's doing well certainly in pain
and and progressing with his rehab
um you know it'll it'll take a minute
and
you know when you're when you're
throwing the football um
man uh just the the torque on your torso
when you throw each time right
uh forget about just being hit uh
there's pain involved and
man he's he's as tough as they come uh
that game a week ago when we played san
francisco
in the second half i mean literally just
as
we're getting ready to go on the field
he said hey
i don't know he's kind of like mumbling
a little bit and i'm leaning on his
words
because i didn't know if he had a play
or something and he said i don't think i
can
i can go in and and it was the first
time in 15 years where
right away i knew how serious it was and
how you know the condition he was in and
so james began to warm up and get ready
but
um it takes a lot for for someone like
drew to not
not be able to finish a game and it was
a lot and uh
man the the toughness he showed and
finishing that
uh that first half uh is pretty amazing
in a few minutes i have left with you
here uh sean how does this team compare
to your previous super bowl winning one
i mean how how
how is this lining up in a manner in
which you know
or you feel in your gut you feel just
with your uh
own football sense that this has
the the makings where does that start
yeah look it's a good question
um going back you know the the 19
much like pittsburgh right now got off
to that you know nine
ten i don't know how many in a row at
the beginning of the year
uh that that type of start and so pretty
soon you find yourself
when that happens winning some games may
be close at the end and then winning
some games
just like you see with what they're
doing and they're doing a great job
um our 11 team was was extremely
talented and
and we ended up in the second round of
the playoffs
um man we had a tough one in minnesota
obviously in 17
uh 18 we had a good team and and we're
in the championship game
i i think this i'm encouraged with how
we're playing on defense the last three
weeks
you know we went on the road a few weeks
back in chicago
with a bunch of injuries on offense and
and we did a good job of of winning a
tough game
uh with a lot of guys out and then that
following week
in tampa bay was a big game obviously
they're a good football team
um we we played extremely well
defensively and and
and i think you know this this word
confidence
generally is manifested you know through
demonstrated ability on the field what
you can wish for or hope for
or want to have confidence but it has to
happen and you have to have positive
results and i i feel like we've begun to
see that defensively
and i think we played a real good
complimentary game our kicking game has
been
on point uh i think the field position
battle a lot of those things that it
takes to win in our league so
look it it gives you a chance and then
you know all you're hoping for
uh when the season ends is an
opportunity to to get in the postseason
and then
uh kind of go from there so before i let
you go i mean your voice kind of trailed
off there when you mentioned the
championship game in 2018 we know what
happened in that game i
i gotta be honest with you i do not miss
past interference being reviewable i
don't miss it one
split second i think i don't think
anyone else does
uh i think that look there there were a
number of things
the i don't think people like to see the
game stopped a lot right
and and so everyone wants a flow to the
game and
look inside two minutes the challenge
for everyone is
is really back in new york uh with
review and plays in a two-minute drill i
think we've done a good job
by and large with that and so uh it was
just one of those plays and
you know you you you hope that uh when
your career is over you're on the better
end then
than the uh the other end right i know
so i guess uh
in your capacity with the competition
committee um
what what so far do you think will be on
the radar screen
is it possible there's a rule change
that you're thinking of right now if so
what would that be
well you always start with player health
and safety i think and and
one of the challenges that the official
officiate the officials have
or you know the helmet to helmets
lowering the head uh
so i we're gonna i know continue to work
on clearing that or cleaning that up and
and trying to educate our players um
and then outside of that um you know
generally speaking i i think
look we just finished a unique training
camp so as we look forward i'm going all
the way to next training camp
you know how many preseason games it
looks like 17 regular season games
what's the
you know one of the things that takes
place when you have something like this
unique season with covet is there are a
few things
when we sooner than later hopefully get
back to normal
there are a few things you've learned in
in whether that's
uh just in the zoom meetings you know or
companies going to travel a little less
because they found out that they can
uh conduct business in in a in a
reasonable fashion
there'll be a few things that that we've
learned as a league i'm sure when we
look back
and then i guess last one for you on
that front is what about the other side
of things you you said
in terms of helmet to helmet to get that
more um
you know buttoned up so players
understand where the strike zone is a
little bit better or not dipping their
heads
what about uh making that reviewable
because so many times you see a hit
that uh is called out of just an
abundance of caution by the officials
who do know that they are the the first
line of defense here
uh and it costs you 15 yards that you
shouldn't have cost
uh and i know that the unintended
consequence would be to stop the game
and say
it wasn't called it should be called and
people go crazy over that but
what about just cleaning that up letting
the eye in the sky kind of help uh
get right what was wrong yeah it's a
great point i i think the one thing
and we've talked about this the uh
you know it's harder and harder to
officiate our game not only just the
speed of the game but with some of the
the things we're asking the officials to
do and and i i personally think as we
look at reducing
the variables for the officials um i
think
you get a better performance and so how
do we do that uh
how do we do that for them uh we're
seeing an influx of new official
new officials coming into our league
they're doing a great job but how do we
reduce the variables
and maybe take some some some stuff off
of their plate so they can continue to
to operate uh at a high level sean
appreciate the time man
really uh i'm thankful for our
friendship thankful for you calling in
the show
and thankful for your twitter thumb when
you see a roddy white tweet i'm thankful
for that listen i i'm thankful
that your hands got feeling back in it
it only took 11 years
it only took that long happy
thanksgiving to you guys
and always rich thanks for having me on
right brother thank you that's sean
payton saints head coach right here in
the rich eisen show
great shot right there hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here